[Music]
welcome to how the light gets in thank
you thanks for having me could you tell
us a little bit about who you are and
yeah your work with developmental
economics in africa um yes of course so
um yes you've said my name ekka
i am the director of the african
leadership center at king's college
london
um right now uh myself a student of
development economics
but from a very heterodox perspective so
uh a critical scholar is how i like to
frame myself
um and you know if i take that as a as a
you know departure for sort of thinking
about my work it's really about
thinking about how economics is
influenced by other disciplines and
influences other disciplines because of
the dynamic character of reality uh
really but also
questioning um sort of the frameworks
that have been given to us that don't
quite deliver what they've promised on
the subject of development this
contentious subject of development so
given your critical stance to some of
these frameworks can you say a little
bit about what you think the main
weaknesses of the ways through which we
approach development these days are um
so a key one which you know the you know
whole
group of people that uh have this stunts
as well
um is the sort of uh the the market
fundamentalist approach that really
insists on how
um you know that markets uh are more
significant element
of development processes and outcomes
and fails to engage with the reality
that actually markets alongside a host
of other entities including states
including societies are very closely
interlinked
and interdependent
so we tend to think of markets as having
a separate life of their own
they they exist in this kind of vacuum
almost but in reality they are supported
by a whole other network of things
including as you said states and state
infrastructure and all the rest of it
does that have an implication of how we
think of economics more generally apart
from developmental economics i think
absolutely because a lot of the the
points and the arguments that we debate
and reflect on within development
economics are those of us working
especially on parts of the global south
in asia and africa apply in other parts
of the world and i think
for instance if we bring it to where we
are in the uk and think of this very
this current a covid period how the
state has had to step in to think about
it's always been there but we just see
it more clearly stepping in to address a
lot of the challenges that have been
wrought by the pandemic we think of the
significance of industrial development
manufacturing when supply chains were
failing especially at the beginning of
the pandemic we see how a state you know
led by a conservative government
is really pushing in terms of the sort
of finance and funding that's coming
from that realm to address uh you know
this this reality and i think the uk is
not alone in that where can we can we
draw a line between a kind of sort of
neo-colonialist
foreign interference and foreign aid
especially given the fraud history of
the uk as a sort of empire and the
relationship it's had with many of the
countries that it directs foreign aid to
today
is there a clear-cut distinction there
how do we think of that i think that's
that's a you know very good question
along with the others you've asked um it
is very complex and complicated but we
we do have to begin to make sense of how
we unpack that uh because the reality is
that we these those interlinkages exist
yes a lot of them if i think of you know
parts of the continent of africa that i
study a lot of them are rooted in you
know
really horrific colonial experiences but
they continue to exist um but what i
think is most significant is the agency
of those in the former colonized world
the agency they have in how those
resources are utilized so this foreign
investment what purpose does it serve
who decides the purpose that it should
serve
and also making sure of course the
benefits um accrue to wider parts of
society as well yeah so that's a way
with development
always whether the money actually goes
into helping local communities or
whether these are always opportunities
for big businesses to come in and make a
quick profit from a new country a new
market
again what are the what are the sort of
safeguards that we can put in place to
to prevent that from happening um so i
think certainly thinking more long term
as opposed to short term you know i'm
someone who really believes and i know
not everyone will agree with me on this
who really believes um in the
significance of manufacturing and
industrial development but this is a
long-term endeavor it's not going to
yield quick you know quick uh outcomes
you know it's it's about processes about
putting the sort of infrastructure in
place that will enable that it's also
about thinking of you know large-scale
infrastructure thinking about
industrialization on a large scale but
also on a small scale as well um and and
i think from there that's why we're
thinking about you know the kind of jobs
being created from that how lasting
they're going to be what what you know
those sort of processes also mean for
relationships between workers and
employers as well so we have to be
thinking of productive work you know we
know a lot about the working poor so
these cannot be processes that sort of
expand that part of society when it
comes to development a critique that is
often aired as this kind of like
one-size-fits-all approach is there a
way of doing this differently or are we
just sort of fated to
just think of certain models and then
just try and apply them to other places
again i think you know a very very
important point post development
theories are you know hot on this and
often make the point that you know
development really is imperialism by
another name and i think you know i
would say you can see where they're
coming from and that the idea that a
perfect model exists that everyone is
working towards um is of course
problematic there is the complexity
though the fact that the the global
economy is structured in a particular
way and participation in that requires
certain things of all those operating
within that global economy nonetheless i
think there must be space for new ways
of doing certain things things new ways
of thinking the hierarchy is in
knowledge and who knows and who presents
these models and who says what progress
looks like we have to be open to
thinking again about what progress look
like what progress looks like and what
progress might be and understanding of
that can be dynamic and can change over
time and will not be one-size-fits-all
it will look different for certain parts
of the same country you know i say all
of that recognizing of course it's very
complicated to plan also on that basis
on the basis of you know difference in
all of this uh various spaces you know i
don't have easy answers to that but i
think some humility
from a lot of us that you know
put ourselves forward as experts becomes
very significant and very important and
a willingness to say okay we're trying
this is not working we need to step back
and rather than blame those communities
recognize the flaws in some of our
thinking we have to learn as we go on
some of these issues is that where some
of the interdisciplinary kind of
thinking that you mentioned the
beginning comes in
using knowledge from anthropologists
ethnologists historians and not just
have economists that maybe don't have a
very good understanding of you know a
particular local history or the the
customs of a particular part of a
country is that where that can help
inform the policy that economists then
design absolutely absolutely that
interdisciplinarity that recognition of
the dynamic character reality is has to
be central within that and i think in
addition to that we have to think again
of what knowledge looks like it's not
just those of us in universities in the
uk or in europe in the u.s on the
continent itself in nigeria and kenya in
south africa it's people outside of the
academy as well people living in those
spaces
it's oral histories as well and rather
than
demean those by suggesting that because
they're not in books it's not proper
knowledge we have to retrain ourselves
to you know to think again of how we
engage with that material retrain
ourselves to engage with that material
and understand that material as well you
recently published a paper
on african fashion futures where you
wrote on creative economies in relation
to local development tell us a little
bit about that work no of course so that
was an exciting
it's part of an exciting project that
i'm carrying out with colleagues at
kings as well so there's more to come on
that um but this particular piece was an
exploratory piece where we're asking
questions
around the conversations that i had
about global value chains and especially
the positioning of african firms within
that quite often when we are you know
this on the subject of global value
chains the narrative is how african
firms fit into the lower ends of the
value chain and our research engaging
with fashion designers in two very
important fashion cities um in the world
i would argue in lagos and in nairobi um
showed immense innovation originality
that is lost if we think of firms in on
the continent as only um carrying out
activities such as cutting and making
and sewing or pattern making
as opposed to sort of design right those
higher value activities and so we are
arguing that
even that gvc framing we have to think
again of the place of firms in the
global south we have to think of them as
potentially lead firms so at least begin
to open the space for a conversation
that can locate them and recognize them
as lead firms
you also work on post-conflict
reconstruction
the economic costs of conflict
afghanistan has been in the news
recently and the attempts at nation
building there and the enormous cost of
the war and everything that followed are
there lessons to be learned from
something that extreme in other contexts
so you know i think you know this is a a
lot of what has come out in a sort of
commentary around this has pointed to
some of the challenges with a sort of
stabilization approach when we're
thinking of engagement with uh context
that are affected by conflict the idea
that what we want to do is stem the tide
and
just keep things stable and calm
regardless of the implications of that
on uh contexts and communities within
that space what voice there is um in
within those spaces
in terms of the kind of policy that's
driven um at higher levels as well is
very critical i think around that and if
i speak you know spaces i'm more
familiar with thinking of uh context in
northeastern nigeria you know i think
for instance the the approach to that
conflict that has really been about
um you know this is this is terrorism
and we have to just uh throw everything
at it uh to stem that as opposed to
thinking what are the dynamics that have
underpinned this um how can we engage
that and it is also a long-term endeavor
there are no easy responses to this
these very harsh military responses you
see in afghanistan how long that's gone
on for and in the end it's not
sufficient because it's never sufficient
one has to work and think with those in
that space and again humility humility
recognizing when we don't fully
understand or fully know um and getting
on board those who know better than us
but we have to admit that we don't fully
know to be able to do that
yeah i think especially in the case of
afghanistan it was again proof of the
lack of local knowledge and
the the very short patience 20 years
was deemed a forever war but of course
20 years to build a nation
might not be enough
how has your work impacted you on a more
personal level and maybe also your
politics does your work inform your
politics does your politics inform your
work no i think absolutely i mean it it
has um
you know this is it's a good question
actually
i mean personally i i've come from a
place
um where i'm you know i'm nigerian i
grew up in nigeria born in lagos and you
know coming out to the uk to study
thinking of how parts of the world that
i'm familiar with are presented were not
always recognizable in the classroom um
the sort of terms epithets used to
describe the spaces were not familiar to
me in many many cases sort of blanket
description of you know these spaces is
you know
this is a poor country as always
conflict here
i recognize those spaces are far more
complex than what was presented and so
it's been very important to my in my
work to be complex it's not been easy
and i you know quite often you know
carrying out research writing a paper
and banging my head against the wall
because the line is not it's not a
straight line to my response or to my
result but that process is so enriching
because
it's forced me to also accept and to
understand it is complex and that in
itself is the result it is complex and
walking with that grasping that what can
we engage in that complexity what do we
have to park in that complexity and come
back to and as academics i mean it's a
lifetime of work to do around that but
obviously your work also
is very close to public policy and it
forms public policy
politics ultimately is about action can
we incorporate some of that
nuance and ambivalence and how we
actually go on to
act in the world and practice in the
world or do we ultimately have to come
down on one side or the other when it
comes to that i think we can absolutely
include that ambivalence and that
uncertainty in how we carry out the work
we do i mean a lot of my work a very
important part of my work that i enjoy
immensely is teaching and this is a very
important space for engagement students
you know very very bright students that
come to us at the african leadership
center we have two masters programs and
leadership and development and security
oh sorry on global leadership and peace
building um and you know teaching them
in class that there aren't certainties
you know we provide them with the vast
array of scholarship that there is the
the tools for complex thinking around
the things they're going to do but also
this sense of humility you guys are
going to say to them you're going to go
on to lead all kinds of processes but
you must travel with a sense of i always
have something to learn and i have
something to learn in these spaces that
i'm going to you know who i learn from
may not be what i had in my mind so this
is a very important space i think that
that training
is a very important space um for that
work but i think certainly as academics
you know we contribute to the work i
mean i've been engaged in conversations
about uk africa uh trade engagement and
the sort of post-brexit era you know
whoever who's listening i don't know but
at least that work has to be out there
and i have to be in those spaces to have
those conversations as well okay thank
you very much thank you so much for
having me
for more debates talks and interviews
subscribe today to the institute of art
and ideas at iai tv
you